[Musique]
mercier je suis maître de conférences en
histoire contemporaine à l'université de
bordeaux et j'étais rapporteur de
l'atelier démocratie citoyenneté laïcité
alors à université 133 dans l'atelier
comme d'ailleurs dans les autres
ateliers
nous avons procédé un peu à la manière
des auditions parlementaires
c'est à dire que des universitaires des
experts ont écouté des élus soient des
députés soient des élus locaux
ils ont aussi lu ce que les militants
avaient dit ans dans la grande enquête
effectuée par par le moderne un
consensus pour considérer que le plein
exercice de la citoyenneté reposer sur
des vertus et des vertus qui ne sont pas
innés qu'il suppose une éducation
d'où l'importance du développement de
cet apprentissage de la citoyenneté à
l'école mais aussi dans le tissu
associatif dans ce qu'on appelle
l'éducation populaire
et puis renforcé à l'échelon local dans
une idée de décentralisation de
subsidiarité tout à fait propre au
centre les liens entre les élus locaux
le monde associatif et les acteurs
éducatifs de l'éducation nationale
certaines personnes auditionnées pouvez
manifester une inquiétude sur
l'évolution récente notamment la très
faible participation au second tour des
municipales dans certains cas certains
se sont inquiétés de ce que brice
teinturier
les graphes le plus rien à en
sorte d'individualisme qui mineraient de
l'intérieur le contrat démocratique et
donc là la question qui nous traverse s
était de savoir si cet épuisement
démocratique était liée en fait c'est un
phénomène social dans lequel chacun
avait sa part de responsabilité
oui c'était les élus le personnel
politique qui en était responsable
on a aussi pointé la le rôle des médias
d'information continue notamment sur
tout ce qu'ils peuvent avoir d'ambigu
dans la le montage en épingle de faits
divers ou ou de fait qui deviennent
sensationnel ce qui était en cause aussi
c'était le développement des réseaux
sociaux comme
espace alternatif d'information alors
c'est face à cet élément cette
reconfiguration de l'information et bien
beaucoup ont plaidé pour développer
l'éducation aux médias non seulement au
sein de l'école mais aussi tout au long
de la vie puisque les plus âgées ne sont
pas moins vulnérable que les enfants et
les adolescents au fait qu'est rose au
conspirationnisme au complotisme
concernant les enduits la
représentativité c
c'est fondamentalement la question de
savoir si le citoyen se reconnaît dans
ce qui l'a élu et le procès trop souvent
fait aux élites et aux élites politiques
qui y est d'être déconnectés du terrain
et je crois que dans l'atelier on a pu
mesurer à quel point ce procès était
infondée parce qu'on a découvert le
universitaire qui les députés étaient
des femmes et des hommes comme les
autres il faut réussir à combler ce
procès de principe qui est fait à ses
élites
[Musique]
ben on doit tout pour la première de six
démocrates sur un but qui au coeur de
notre pacte républicain l'étape de
démocratie donc nous aurons l'occasion
d'entendre et de discuter avec marc
fesneau ministre délégué auprès du
premier chargé des relations avec le
parlement de la participation citoyenne
qui est également vice président du
mouvement démocrate est également sa
raillerie ses craintes à l'état chargé
de la jeunesse et de l'engagement auprès
du ministre de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports
isabelle florennes également michel
mercier ancien garde des sceaux et
laurence vichnievsky député du
puy-de-dôme membre de la commission des
lois
alors nous savons ici au mouvement
démocrate pour reprendre les mots de
marc sangnier que la démocratie est le
régime qui doit partait au maximum la
conscience et la responsabilité de
chacun
le modèle démocratique libéral que
certains appellent occidentale semblait
il ya vingt ans encore s'imposer
progressivement sur les sur les cinq
continents
à la suite de la chute des républiques
soviétiques et l'émergence des
démocraties en europe de l'est et en
amérique latine
nous avions tort hier de le croire si
établissent notre modèle puisqu'il est
aujourd'hui profondément attaqué deux
parlements nous aurions surtout encore
aujourd'hui de considérer que ce même
risque qui est étranger à notre
démocratie française
le cevipof ainsi interrogé les français
en avril dernier en plein confinement et
44% estimé qu en démocratie rien
n'avance qui vaudrait mieux moins de
démocratie mais plus d'efficacité
bien entendu le souhait d'un exécutif
fort était plébiscité par confinement le
comprends mais aussi aussi que ces
chiffres ne sont qu'un symptôme de plus
aux mâles démocratique français
puisqu'en janvier donc avant la crise
sanitaire que nous avons connus déjà 64
% des français considéraient que la
démocratie fonctionne mal dans notre
pays
donc pour démarrer ces débats je vais
céder la parole il est tout de suite à
marc fesneau avec une première question
finalement comment est-ce qu'on en est
arrivé là et comment réconcilier aux
yeux des français la démocratie et
lanester efficacité des pouvoirs publics
bonjour à toutes et à tous heureux de
vous rejoindre ce matin peut-être que
les éléments pas être trop long pour
qu'on puisse échanger les uns avec les
autres
d'abord d'où vient notre crise c'est
très compliqué détaillé en cinq minutes
mais comme l'a très bien dit pierre gens
que je salue il ya des éléments vaut
bien deux de crispation et de crise qui
sont liés à plusieurs phénomènes me
semble utile moi je pense que le premier
quand même pour revenir à la base des
choses c'est le sentiment qu'ont vu les
citoyens depuis 30 40 ou 50 ans
l'incapacité qui était de l'incapacité
des responsables publics à transformer
les choses ou un vrai sur leur quotidien
je pense que dès lors que nous étions
une somme de rentrer dans un monde où au
fond la puissance publique tenait le
sentiment d'être assez impuissante
l'utilité du vote s'est amoindrie au fur
et à mesure ceux-ci se double d'ailleurs
d'un élément nouveau qui a été celui de
l'émergence en tout cas aux yeux des
citoyens de mondialisation de nos encore
plus le sentiment d'incapacité
d'inutilité des responsables publics
nationaux
tout ça crée une situation d'impuissance
et qui fait que évidemment par ya pu y
avoir aussi eu des attitudes des
comportements étaient encore plus décalé
compte tenu de ce qu'étaient les
difficultés la crise de légitimité est
et qui ont agrandi gouffre on doit
donner le sentiment qu'il y avait une
élite qui se partageaient au fond les
ors de la république que et que pendant
ce temps là on ne faisait pas sur le
réel bien troisième sujet que je voulais
évoquer me semble-t-il c'est le sujet et
ça c'est plus récent et ça vient aussi
mettre à mal la démocratie me
semble-t-il
c'est l'émergence des réseaux sociaux et
puis le mélange du doute permanent si je
peux dire c'est à dire le fait que toute
vérité devient discutable tout fait
devient discutable on l'a très bien vu
d'ailleurs dans la crise due qu'au vu du
travail c'était extrêmement visible vous
pouvez toujours dire que ce qui
ressemble à une voiture paraît être une
voiture si quelqu'un vous dit maintenant
j'ai l'impression que c'est un éléphant
rose
après tout c'est discutable et je
rappelle on le disait aux journées
parlementaires l'autre jour il ya quand
même 10 10 ou 12 % de gens en france qui
sont des plates east c'est à dire des
gens qui pensent que la terre n'est pas
ronde faut pas sous-estimer ça pourrait
prêter à sourire au fond ne faut pas
sous-estimer les aider dès le moment
qu'on vit dans le monde où au fond tout
est discutable et tout fait scientifique
est discutable et comme les
scientifiques eux mêmes
on l'a vu au moment de la duc au vide
entre sa scène des choses qui ne sont
pas fondés sur l'expérimentation
l'expérience la controverse parce que la
science est toujours eu la controverse
assez normal et que chacun peut venir
sur un plateau dire tout et son
contraire d'ailleurs parfois la même
personne sans que ça pose de problème
évidemment ça vient troubler les esprits
parce que si même les scientifiques
semblent eux-mêmes être théoricien du
complotisme alors que ça devrait être le
mieux qu'un de plus éloignés évidemment
on a une difficulté donc tout ça
participe une grande difficulté alors
c'est compliqué de résoudre tous les
problèmes à la fois je pense qu'il ya
comme un sujet c'est que c'est que quand
même quand on est responsable public on
s'attache à essayer de résoudre les
problèmes des français et à parler
d'autre chose
c'est souvent pour ça même si je pense
que ça s'amoindrit les élus locaux en
particulier quand j'ai les élus locaux
je pense les maires discuterons qui est
de des conseillers régionaux mais où des
conseillers départementaux sans vouloir
leur faire de peine mais les maires
pourquoi ils sont plus publicité parce
que au fond même si c'est quand
j'habitais aussi aujourd'hui on a un
sentiment qu'en par l'eau mais répandue
de problème il a une capacité à y
répondre
parfois il le fait mal ce qu'il dit
répond pas mais parfois il le fait bien
et nous compter au moins je vais
demander de faire s'il l'a fait donc ça
c'est quand même un élément mais en tout
cas je pense que pour les responsables
publics nationaux
l'exigence seul mot d'essayer de
répondre à la chose
2 il faut rien lâcher sur sur le fait
que rien ne se décide sans se tromper il
faut avoir un peu de doute mais quand
même sens des faits qui sont un peu
établi
on ne gouverne pas avec des sentiments
du complotisme moi je pense que ce
serait une erreur
l'autre un petit addendum si on essaie
aussi de ne pas cultiver les peurs les
querelles et les antagonismes
mais c'est aussi une façon de gouverner
mais en tout cas je pense qu'il faut
s'appuyer là dessus il faut s'appuyer
sur des secrets on peut pas avoir
vous avez vu tous les mac on a eu sur la
singette au delà des mots dont on a
comme le sentiment qu'on revient jeudi
sous l'oeil de certains qu'ils peuvent
je pense que quand est arrivée la
voiture aux côtés d'arriver à
l'électricité ou s'est retrouvé dans des
débats de même maintenant d'expliquer
que les l'électricité allaient produire
des choses horribles avec transformer
donc on est sur les mêmes peurs mais on
est sur des peurs millénaire si je peux
dire est dans un monde hyper hyper
rationaliser sa femme
saran interrogatifs et ceci dit c'est
pas tout à fait nouveau de prendre
protège donc ça c'est un deuxième
élément
et puis 3 pour finir pardon je vais
d'abord être un plomb il sent qu'il faut
qu'on essaie de renouveler nos pratiques
démocratiques pense aux pratiques
démocratiques nationales en particulier
du ministre de la relation des relations
avec le parlement et de la participation
citoyenne
je ne viens pas faire de prosélytisme de
biscuits je pense que la capacité qu'on
a à la fois à ne pas opposer les deux
participatif est représentatif c'est
qu'est la légitimité démocratique c'est
comme le représenter n'empêche pas qu'il
faut s'appuyer sur du participative
ça se fait d'ailleurs en local pour ça
que je comprends pas que certains ses
frais en national ça se fait en local il
faut essayer de le développer en
national pour plutôt enrichir apaisé les
débats et que les parlementaires
puissent s'en saisir dans de bonnes
conditions mais après c'est le travail
des parlementaires
ça me met le deuxième point c'est sans
doute la modernisation institutionnelle
que nous portons depuis longtemps
françois qui provoque ce temps là un jeu
disons les choses comme elles sont hélas
parti et l'arrêt régionales et elle
participe aussi d'une révision du
fonctionnement des parlementaires et du
parlement s'est pas seulement les hémois
qui était quelques parlementaires et
fréquenter les instances parlementaires
de lui maintenant à une grande paire
d'années je reconnais volontiers que
chacun est un peu responsable de la part
du discrédit kaunas maintenant sur le
parlement on aura l'occasion d'en parler
mais il sent que c'est un élément quand
même il faut pas sous-estimer jeu je
trouve que parfois les parlementaires
moi qui suis désormais du côté obscur de
la force c'est-à-dire du gouvernement
mais les parlementaires aussi se prête
assez facilement ou aux critiques en
appui sens quand vous retrouvez avec
détecte avec deux ou trois mille
amendements au fond vous nourrissez le
sentiment un temps antiparlementaire et
quand des débats se nouent sur des
choses anecdotiques essentielle ça me
paraît ça me parait dommage je finis
juste en disant voilà il n'y a amené
année un truc intéressant qui est la
convention citoyenne qui a été lancé par
le président c'est pas très simple de
faire atterrir sarr et qu'on préfère
atterrissent à nos sphères parlementaire
j'aurais salue au passage la réforme m6
est une fée à bas bruit même si on n'est
pas une révolution du c'est ce qui a été
voté par les parlementaires cette
semaine est celle de nous écouter et à
voir une balade ans qui a été rapporteur
il rapporterait efficace rapporteur qui
a parlé de compromis qu'on fasse
attaques dans de très bonnes conditions
c'est pas la révolution mais un point ça
redonne quelques éléments pour faire en
sorte que de la participation citoyenne
puisse se développer
voilà j'ai été trop long mais j'ai à peu
près tout dit ce que je voulais dire
merci beaucoup marque justement tu
l'évoquait et c'était aussi l'un des
sujets qu'on avait vu dans le tête
chercheuse de l'université 133 quitter
la défiance entre les hommes et les
femmes politiques donc justement elodie
tu nous a rejoint et le dit jacky
laforge qui est député
de l'isère membre de la commission des
lois comment est-ce que d'après toi on
peut re monétiser le vote aux yeux des
français alors très très grande question
alors je m'entends en écho c'est normal
bon là ça y est c'est bon t'es plus
d'écho si j'étais de l'écho mais c'est
pas grave je vais m'en temps comment re
monitise et le vote alors ça a déjà été
évoqué par par marc on voit que
l'abstention augmente au fur et à mesure
des scrutins quand bien même jusqu'ici
les questions on va dire municipal ou en
tout cas locale et était préservée on a
vu aux dernières élections pendant la
crise du duc au vide qui malgré tout une
une baisse de la participation est
finalement au second tour
c'est quand même compliqué tout mettre
sur entre guillemets à tout mettre sur
le dos du du virus donc donc à cette
baisse de la participation mais
finalement presqu'un un désamour c'est à
dire des représentants donc la question
d'une pause 1 c'est comment finalement
doté en jean et joua sa rage si aux plus
jeunes on leur donne envie d'aller voter
avec ce tir comme on donne envie de
participer
et finalement je crois que je vais un
peu peut-être jeté un pavé dans la marre
qu'il faut aussi que les noms centre
représenté c'est à dire qu'il faut
s'identifier à leurs représentants même
si effectivement on tourne un peu
en boucle ça me parait ça me paraît
essentiel je crois que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ne s'identifie pas à leurs
représentants il ya un décalage qui se
fait il ya un jeu parfois aussi dans
l'expression dans la façon de se
comporter et je crois que ce décalage de
là il est les hippies se renforce et
qu'en tout cas il fait que tu as un
certain nombre de concitoyens se
détournent de pleurs de leur vote
et puis aussi on a un contexte où les
les personnes attendent finalement une
réponse immédiate
elle a évoqué aussi marc voilà certains
pensent que la terre est plate
il ya une ambiance complotistes il ya
aussi l'important c'était nos socios qui
fait que des épiphénomènes donc en tout
cas ce qu'ils pouvaient être considérées
comme des faits divers deviennent des
sujets d'actualité alors c'est pour
quand la minijupe rencontre peut montrer
ce qu'on brûlât nicole c'est bien toute
la place bon donc il ya des êtres
volonté d'avoir une réponse immédiate
mais la politique
d'ailleurs avec la nomination de
françois c'est aussi le temps long donc
apporter des réponses mais c'est pas des
réponses qu'on va pouvoir apporter de
tout de suite sur comment est-ce qu'on
commune est de 6 le vote c'est tout un
c'est tout un processus
j'étais ce matin en bureau municipal et
même les élus parfois à se désintéresse
des commissions communales
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils s'en détournent
parce qu'ils se sentent pas réellement
acteurs et qui se pare également à
participer dans ces commissions et donc
par extension je pense qu'il faut aussi
que les personnes sont réellement
investi dans les prises de décision et
el haouz
bien pourquoi à la participation de nos
concitoyens qui peuvent être sollicités
il pleut façon sur des points très
précis notre façon plus générale ou sur
le temps long aussi donc je pense que
c'est extrêmement important de les faire
participer donc pour pas être plus
longue et parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'intervenants
c'est vrai qu'on a on peut se poser la
question du vote obligatoire mais on
développe fait vote électronique
il y avait un sujet aussi sur le vote
par correspondance
je crois aussi qu'il ya une nécessité de
revoir la place parlement parce que
c'est là où on parle et donc je crois
qu'il faut réellement mark addy chacune
et chacun des parlementaires du mieux
qu'il le peut se saisissent aussi de
tous les pouvoirs qui existent et qui
donnait au parlement il faut pas
attendre qu'on nous laisse la place
il faut prendre la place et c'est pas
forcément facile comme lettre qu'il est
passé de l'autre côté de la barrière
mais la barrière du parlement voilà il
faut aussi qu'on exerce de tous nos
problèmes qui sont celles d'une du poids
exécutif et puis bascule époque rôle
dans un rôle de représentation qui ne va
pas forcément toujours dans le sens de
style de ce que le gouvernement voudrait
faire donc je pense qu'on a su parce qu
on est responsable on est acteur aussi
donc
donc voilà donc aux redmen parce qu'il
faut se reconnaître dans leur représente
je pense qu'il faut les impliquer plus
quand les prises de zénith vision et
pense qu'il faut que le parlement assume
la dépendance son rôle entièrement
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif prenne vraiment
tout toute sa place merci beaucoup
alors merci beaucoup et elodie tu
parlais justement de passer la barrière
je me dirige donc vers sarah qu'il a
récemment franchi qui est donc devenu
secrétaire d'état chargée de la jeunesse
et de l'engagement auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports
donc ça va on l'a vu sur plusieurs
plusieurs interventions la question de
la jeunesse est évidemment fondamental
de sa relation à la démocratie moi je
vous les citer un seul chiffre pour le
pour le introduire ce sujet là le
cevipof a fait a fait une étude en 2017
sur le rapport des jeunes et de la
démocratie et moins de la moitié des
jeunes pensent à calais voter aux
élections était un bon moyen
d'influencer des décisions politiques en
france
comment est ce qu'on arrive à favoriser
l'engagement au sein au sein de la
jeunesse on l'a vu se lever sur des
causes comment est ce que on arrive à
revaloriser le rôle des élections dans
l'expression citoyenne des jeunes merci
eu du plomb tour comme elle le dit
j'espère que ça
passer ça pour répondre à nous écouter
mandant dans l'est et d'élodie remarques
parce que le chiffre quand tu donnes est
inquiétant et donc du coup est ce que
notre démocratie est en danger
en jeune cheveux 3 par an le vote pour
un jeune en jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans à
sept chances sur dix de ne pas aller
voter ou cinq buts comme ça nous
questionnent parce qu'en plus finir en
parallèle avec une montée mais des
violences voire la fréquence des
violences contre les institutions contre
les symboles excès de la démocratie et
des écharpes des élus locaux
et puis cette opposition et elodie en a
on a très bien la démocratie
représentative et puis finalement les
autres sur cette ligne là moi je suis
pour l'allemagne où le mahatma
démocratie et la lni banque centrale
mais pour les jeunes en particulier
comment et d'où les accotements comment
on les amène à reconnaître être
démocratie représentative est comme lui
dans tous extrêmement loin est ce que
notre jeunesse mme est engagé
la réponse est oui la réponse est
en fait pour garder la manière dont ils
réinventent il nous pousse à nos
questions sur la transition
environnementale pour notre capacité à
nous tenir pour ne pas accepter
aujourd'hui de ne pas regarder quand on
voit avec les rideaux sur le meilleur et
le pire
les meilleurs c'est ces grands élans de
saisissement de deux projets pourtant
que des solutions c'est m3 de faire
vivre à telle heure c'est le meilleur
est évidemment une jeunesse s'engage
c'est une jeunesse qu'on accompagne dans
l'engagement et qu'on amène jusqu'au
bout de la justesse de la démocratie
représentative et pour ça on a plusieurs
chemins le premier c'est tout le pôle
autour de la démocratie communale de la
démocratie ni je l' ai vu passer
également tueur évidemment la
sensibilisation la passion avec les
conseils les seuils minimaux jeunes
cette semaine pendant ma semaine
il ya l'émotion au collège et au lycée
déjà dès les comptes et est finalement
élection d co délégué est une avancée au
risque est aussi la capacité retrouve
les jeunes à être dans l'action dans une
associative lors d'une mission locale ou
dans des structures nos territoires
quand on se rend compte que partie
influer sur le présent un flux est ce
qu'on la dit non alors il ya deux
manières compris entre 2,1 de la
représentativité de l'exercice
démocratique et 3 d'accepter que sa
position paraît peut être pas eu de
rythme mais pour ça il faut tout un
chemin un chemin le plus jeune âge mais
je ne crois plus classique à 18 mois
exclusivement 18
donc c'est une manière d'accepter
quand dans notre société et m'exprime
pas exclusivement par le code de lot et
c'est là où chacun a vocation à être
responsables être acteur et pour
répondre à la nôtre aujourd'hui
et comment est-ce que nous sommes tous
responsables à règlement oui à l'école
on doit avoir encore plus de
sensibilisation sur les questions
d'apprentissage de la citoyenneté
doyenne puisque nos instituts en sont
très peu connus
comment vous voulez adhérer à quelque
chose nous on est pas et donc là nous
avons une responsabilité parce que je
crois que notre lot de la france où le
système c'est évidemment la démocratie
représentative
mais pour créer de l'adhésion il faut
recréer et aller au bout de l'exercice
c'est à dire ni aussi une une cohérence
qu'on puisse se retrouver dans nos
représentants et ça ça du début et mieux
comprendre le projet ce qui nous amène à
apprendre des détenus ont tellement les
propos de marc du début on prend de
l'exercice ' commentaires voire
l'existant n'y fit en amendes
quelle est la navette parlement tout ça
il ne sait pas si acquis pour être
honnête si acquis et moi je le vois sur
le des jeunes qui ont énormément
d'énergie s'engage
je compte beaucoup de choses mais qui
défend ou de la distance mort de du
questionnement vis-à-vis de nos agents
parce qu'ils ne les comprennent pas et
donc ils les bousculant frontale non pas
parce qu'ils n'y croient pas mais par
contre ne se sentent pas acteur de
l'exercice maintenant comment on fait
vivre ça je crois que c'est un séisme en
général ont chacun a donc une pierre à
la maison que ce soit à l'école que ce
soit les acteurs de l'éducation
populaire
admis aux associations mais ce n'est pas
en le remettant en question l'équipe
la reprise la place de la représentation
de la démocratie représentative
on y arrivera contraire sur le chemin du
meilleur compréhension d'une mise en
musique de participation quelle qu'elle
soit est-ce que la meute c'est la
reconnaissance de l'engagement c'est
finalement comment je vais te dire
demos kratos et le pouvoir au peuple et
le coup droit et au quotidien et donc
c'est finalement comme blanches et mais
eux ne passent pas son énergie à aider à
construire à se comprendre au moins
trouvé le mais le meilleur très bien
merci beaucoup sahara pour ce ce
panorama complet et évidemment ce focus
sur la jeunesse je vais laisser la
parole à michel merci maintenant qui
donc ancien garde des sceaux pour
revenir aussi un petit peu à la question
qu'on avait au départ celle de la
responsabilité leur explosivité aussi
collective tous responsables de la
situation de la démocratie aujourd'hui
on a vu aussi que cette démocratie en
effet elle était plurielle qui avait une
démocratie qui s'exprimait sur les
territoires une démocratie qui était
plus participative une démocratie
sociale aussi qui est nécessaire
d'aborder donc finalement comment est-ce
qu'on rend chacun responsable devant la
protection de ce patrimoine commun
beaucoup je n'ai pas forcément bien
compris la question parce que le saut au
top et difficile mais une première
première chose
par définition la démocratie dit est
toujours au régime fragile
c'est un équilibre à rechercher à
construire entre plusieurs exigences
autres la liberté
la participation de chacun et
l'efficacité correction au public
bien entendu si on a une dictature
démocratique qui soit à faire vos culs
et il faut toujours faire en sorte que
deby focus évoquait ça peut paraître un
truisme
mais c'est quand même une vérité et
hockey sur
longue vie politique je vois que le
champ de l'action de la démocratie était
la fois bien plus vaste qu'il y à
quelques décennies et en même temps plus
controversé ce qui est assez normal seul
engagement
odile plus abstentions c'est vrai mais
je crois aussi qu'il y à plus
d'engagement de citoyens dans d'autres
domaines
quand on voit par exemple tout ce que
font les jeunes dans les équipes de
développements au moyen-orient en
amérique du sud ou ailleurs c'est quand
même une vraie réalité et la démocratie
aujourd'hui elle dépasse les frontières
et on a toute une série de notions
juridiques qui seront un peu anciennes
et qui correspondent à la façon de vivre
d'aujourd'hui et les réseaux sociaux la
technologie fait que ces notions éclate
et qu'elle reconstruire la démocratie
c'est reconstruire aussi ces notions par
exemple je suis très attaché à la notion
de liberté individuelle
mais c'est plus la même notion de
liberté individuelle
aujourd'hui qu'il ya un siècle c'est
évident il y à bien d'autres points dans
lesquelles on souhaite être libre
et la démocratie doit être le régime
politique qui permet de faire en sorte
que les nouvelles conceptions de la
liberté de la vie en commun puisse
réellement s'exercer alors il faut pas
négliger la technique il faut la mettre
à sa place par exemple plusieurs
orateurs on parlait de l'abstention du
vote et que citoyen avait le sentiment
que leur vote n'avait pas grand chose en
fin de compte
ça peut être vrai si vous avez une
élection quelqu'un est élu avec 59 01
eh bien elle et 49,1 quelque chose est
bien se trouveront des possédés en
quelque sorte de l'oms
donc il faut qu'on réfléchisse à des
modes de votation différents qui fasse
que tous les votes contre c'est la
proportionnelle bien sûr mais et qui
doit être comprise correctement il y à
toutes les formes d'engagement qui sont
une réponse quelque part à l'idée que la
politique ne peut plus tout faire quand
on voit l es jeunes qui s'engagent dans
cette vie sociale d'un peu tout ce qui
est l aide aux plus démunis et dans les
camps ville mais aussi dans les
campagnes
c'est parce que la sphère publique ne
fait plus ou ne fait pas et donc les
nouvelles formes d'engagement doivent
être véritablement promu sur la
citoyenneté d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
simplement aller voter tous les 6 ans
tous les quatre ont tous les trois ans
et même si elle a multiplication des
scrutins sexe et tous les deux ans c'est
un engagement concret de tous les jours
quant au pain de démocratie
participative
moi je vous que ça me casse un peu les
oreilles sauf si on donne à cette
démocratie participative impatience très
clair ça veut dire que le citoyen qui
est souvent jeunes des hommes mais ça
peut être seniors participent par son
action un avis en commun c'est plus
qu'une chose elle ça peut être portée
des repas aux personnes âgées
dépendantes ça peut être aidé pour faire
des doigts de la nicotine dans la vie
quotidienne et c'est un canal c'est
aussi une façon de faire vivre
démocratie
il nous appartient à nous centristes
peut être encore plus qu'aux autres
d'inventer d'inventer les modes d'action
du citoyen d'aujourd'hui et de ne pas
l'enfermer uniquement dans le vote
une fois étonné même si ces rendez-vous
sont fondamentaux pour la liberté mais
ils doivent pas être un des seuls rendez
vous elle rendez vous quotidien de la
vie de tous les jours et puis il ya les
grandes actions de développement des
lots lemire a aidé des personnes
d'ailleurs parce que les vagues sont pas
libres je vais donc on voit bien qu'il
faut réinventer une démocratie plus
globale si on veut qu'elle soit plus
réel
merci merci beaucoup
pour ces mots d'espoir aussi sur
l'engagement de la jeunesse de toute la
société
je vais vous faire un message concernant
les commentaires on en reçoit beaucoup
un grand merci
comme cette table ronde sera évidemment
participative on va passer très vite aux
commentaires mais avant il est important
qu'on puisse aborder un sujet qui est
celui des libertés publiques
c'est consubstantiel à la notion de
démocratie et pour ça je vais donner la
parole à laurent synesci qui est député
du puy-de-dôme de la commission des lois
mais également ce qui était magistrate
avant son entrée au parlement
on a évidemment vu que ces libertés été
mise à mal ces derniers mois pour des
bonnes raisons
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire
mais au-delà de ça il ya un petit peu un
état d'esprit qui voudrait dire que
finalement on ne serait plus vraiment
libre en france donc laurence vous donne
la parole sur ce sujet là qu'est ce que
vous vous répondez à sa merci pierre
jean l
vous me direz si on m'entend parce que
moi je faisais très peu entendu
effectivement je l'entends prend l'eau
bon je continue alors sinon je m'arrête
tout style beaucoup de choses ont été
dites et si tu me permet une observation
préliminaire je voudrais remercier jean
noël barrot
notre secrétaire général qui a permis ou
qui a lancé les universités 133 et en
fait des débats qui ont lieu dans le
cadre de cet univers et nous permettent
aujourd'hui de débattre dans de
meilleures conditions encore parce que
nous avons tous beaucoup réfléchi avant
ne se tienne cette et plénière
d'aujourd'hui de ce week end et je pense
que notre pensée s'est affinée avec de
tous et elle est alors pour revenir à la
question précise que tu poses ce matin
je voudrais dire que bien sûr nos
libertés individuelles ont été
renier si je puis dire elles ont été
limités 22 d'hugo vide mais c'est
nécessaire et est important c'est
d'avoir on met le curseur
parce que il y a toujours de liberté qui
oppose
nous avons d'une certaine dans une
certaine mesure la le droit à la santé
et c'est vrai que pour pouvoir exercer
ce noir il faut aujourd'hui dans un
contexte particulier limiter nos
libertés à titre personnel je t'avais
été très très vigilante s'agissant de
l'application stop qu'ovide au demeurant
vous aurez peut-être constaté que les
français ont été très réticents sur
cette application puisqu'elle a été très
peu télécharger et moi à titre personnel
les attachés aux libertés individuelles
et que je suis consciente de la tempête
dans un peu totani totalitaire et
nouvelles technologies
je vais très soucieuse du stockage et de
l'utilisation éventuelle des données qui
pourraient être qui pourraient résulter
de cette de cette application
pierre-jean tu m'as aussi a aussi évoqué
la liberté de manifester qui
sembleraient atteinte aujourd'hui en
raison de manifestations très violentes
ont eu lieu récemment en fait là encore
nous avons le droit à l'intégrité et 6
7/10 magnificient la possibilité de
manifester a été recadrée parce que nous
avons toujours cette liberté
fondamentale
elle a été recadrée de manière à ce que
l'intégrité des manifestants mais aussi
des portes de l'ordre puissent être
préservés
en fait la liberté sur laquelle je
voudrais revenir un peu plus dans le
détail c'est la liberté d'expression
parce que je crois que là il faut
distinguer l'expression de chacun qui
peut parfois être kelly et de fenioux je
ne me souviens plus qu il faisait
allusion tout à l'heure à la terre à la
croyance selon laquelle la terre était
pas peut-être marcq et bondues temps de
galilée je pense que c'était pas une
fille ou de dire que la terre était
plate et qu'elle tournait autour d'elle
m donc est ce qu'aujourd'hui la 5 et
portent atteinte à la légalité des
territoires et il ya notre environnement
c'est très compliqué de trouver la
vérité et je crois qu'il faut plutôt
mettre le curseur du côté de la liberté
c'est le curseur vers la liberté
en revanche il y a les incitations à la
haine les comportements les harcèlements
individuel sur les réseaux sociaux
puisque en fait je crois que ce sont les
nouvelles technologies et les réseaux
sociaux qui nous confronte à ses
difficultés
et là il faut tu es un table et pourvoir
rechercher et punir les auteurs de
telles infractions à ce que ce côté vous
vous souvenez sans doute de la ferme il
a qui m'avait beaucoup choqué et
aujourd'hui après huit mois d'enquêté on
a toujours trouvé qu'un seul auteur
alors que nous c'est un bon coup et nous
devons rechercher plus d'efficacité
parce que aujourd'hui c'est elle qui a
dû c'est cette jeune fille qui est dû
changer de collège taux du change et
c'est un peu le monde le monde à
l'envers
si on ne trouve pas les auteurs qui se
cache sous des pseudos l'on travaillait
là à cette efficacité
eh bien il faut réprimer les cornes et
c'est mon sentiment et il y a aussi le
politiquement correct
alors qui est à son stade extrême à mon
sens aux états unis mais qui nous
parvient en europe toujours impec
continent et je crois qu'il faut être
très attentif aussi politiquement
correct parce nous auraient observé par
exemple que le nul le new york times le
caricature c'est grave
je crois que c'est grave et nous avons
une sorte de fin je crains qu'il n'y ait
une sorte de dictature de minorités qui
s'exprime de façon violente radical sur
les réseaux et qui prennent les ardeurs
de beaucoup d'expressions modérée en
doute comme celle notre mouvement fin de
notre famille parce que on ne se trouve
pas dans le le créneau aujourd'hui
politiquement correct et vous voyez je
crains agissant de notre vote
démocratique ne porte atteinte
aujourd'hui au principe d'égalité avec
son corollaire qui est celui de la
distinction au mérite
lorsque on développe les quotas il faut
être très attentif à mon sens à cette
question est ce que c'est la société que
nous voulons est ce que il est opportun
est ce qu'il est juste et que quelques
routes ne puisse pas à tenir une
conférence que l'on interdise à pâques
de fait la prodige chilien d'eschyle à
lhassa
enfin tout cela me perturbe et je crois
que cela doit interroger notre famille
politique et à l'âge je termine j'ai
peut-être déjà été prolongée mais il y a
tant de sujets à évoquer lorsque la démo
qui est en jeu et je vais bien sûr dans
le onze de suspects exprimées par nos
éminents intervenants de ce matin euma
un échelle
elodie et nous devons trouver les
équilibres sont hâtives et là des blocs
y bat hâtives
nous devons trouver l'équilibré entre le
droit d'expression des minorités mais et
la pression trop forte qu'elles peuvent
elles peuvent exercer et nous devons
pouvoir y met brement sans craindre les
foudres dieu du du harcèlement sur les
réseaux sociaux et nous devons pouvoir
manifester sans crainte d'être exposée
dans son intégrité physique
voilà et était trop longue mais il y a
aussi remercié comme ceux concernant
rythme atteint diversité et en 33 la
laïcité
nous allons débattre de la loi si une
soirée séparatisme
bon enfin je compte beaucoup sur vous
tous et sur nos deux ministres qui sont
aujourd'hui présents à notre table ronde
parce que ça ah oui il faut que les
jeunes s'impliquent
mais michel a raison si les les jeunes 5
qui que différemment et marc oui nous
devons trouver aussi d'autres équilibre
entre les différents
les trois institutions les trois
pouvoirs j'ose dire
mais pour le judiciaire et c'est vrai
que le parlement au droit trouver ou
retrouver sa juste place
merci merci beaucoup en effet tu
abordaient donc des sujets extrêmement
importants qui sont revenus dans les
commentaires notamment pour faire un
tour des questions des amis qui ont
réagi sur les réseaux on a eu pas mal de
réactions sur le fait qu'il fallait
garantir en effet la participation
citoyenne sophie hervé vous avez
notamment mentionné le fait qu'il
faudrait aller vers davantage de
participation citoyenne
que ce soit grâce à la réforme du 16e ou
au sein des collectivités par les
conseils municipaux
on a également sur cette inclusion de la
jeunesse finalement deux questions ce
que j'aimerais mettre en parallèle
puisqu'elle sera importante celle de la
de l'éducation à la citoyenneté qui ont
été rappelés par plusieurs des personnes
en commentaire également celui de
finalement modifié ce ce vote agir
dessus notamment abaissé pourquoi pas le
vote l'âge pour voter à 16 ans
quel est votre avis dessus la
reconnaissance du vote blanc également
en tout cas rendre ce vote peut être un
peu plus représentatif quel est votre
votre avis sur ces succès réaction là et
on salue donc ça vient et pierre qui ont
posé ces questions je sais pas qui
souhaitent prendre la parole dessus
peut-être ça rassure le fait d'abaisser
le vote à 16 ans il ya une réforme du
cese sur le droit de pétition est ce
qu'il faut aller plus loin est ce que
les sujets propres à l'éducation aussi à
la citoyenneté sur les jeunes mais
également les moins jeunes comme le
disait jean williams en commentaire à
notre un autre échange où on est on de
ces chantiers là et toi quel est ton
positionnement
aujourd'hui le buzz
l'élection on a mais l'enjeu disait que
la citoyenneté c'est pour exactement le
droit de vote c'est parce qu'il ya des
points forts et des moments où la droite
n'accède à bon droit et bombay l'action
à l'assemblée nationale il va y avoir
pas ce qu'il faut moi je crois que ce
n'est pas moi le jeu est assez claire
entre 18 et 25 ans alors je me disais oh
no 2 % est-ce que c'est peu dire que nos
jeunes de 16 à 18 ans votre et plus tu
ne crois pas je crois plutôt
il faut aller chercher dans un exercice
des plus importants qui nous amène à
l'enseignement à l'accompagnement du
chesnay jeu la citoyenneté et là il y a
un vrai travail et les opportunités par
exemple le service d'espionnage de
l'univers qui va être un ton être plus
important je suis toutes les expressions
et aujourd'hui l'évolution que nous et
je suis droit de pétition
une des manières de saisir démocratique
et c'est ce que disait marc le débat sur
l'âge 18
je crois qu'il est réducteur le qu'il
mènera qui ouvrira les débats mais ce
qui sonnait sur l'art l'aspiration même
de notre jeunesse et cette aspiration
elle déteint sur une plage mais plutôt
sur ce que des michel sur comment
reconnaître chaque vote cherche chaque
vote compte qu on n'est pas sans nom de
se déplacer voilà en tout cas le partage
battus à la combler c'est ça fait partie
des serpents de mer en tout cas la
position est très claire sur pour pour
continuer sur le sujet on a eu une
réaction d'amandes de camille qui a été
très commentée sur le live sur justement
comment permettre aux jeunes de
d'exprimer ce qu'ils souhaitent exprimer
on a vu et vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
vous même les nombreuses de
manifestations qui ont lieu les sujets
dont s'est saisi la jeunesse et pourtant
donc le taux d'abstention qui reste
assez élevé ça pose la question de
l'enseignement de la citoyenneté elodie
souhaité réagir par rapport à cela
oui merci
merci pierre jean je voulais réagir
parce que j'ai la possibilité dans le
cadre du parlement des enfants
d'intervenir depuis trois ans devant les
classes de cm2 je trouve que c'est un
moment très agréable déjà de pouvoir
discuter avec une classe d'enfants et je
trouve que s'il ya un moment important
des changes et ils ont des questions ils
ont des questions sans filtre et on voit
qu'ils sont très curieux de du
fonctionnement de nos institutions du
rôle du voile à d'un député
à quoi ça sert donc je pense que c'est
des opérations qui sont peut-être
aujourd'hui peut-être un peu trop
confidentielle ou en tout cas je pense
que ça pourrait être élargie alors il
s'agit pas que chaque parlementaire est
chaque fois dans toutes les classes
parce qu'on n'aurait pas la capacité de
le faire
mais en tout cas ça permet au delà des
enfants aussi de sensibiliser les
enseignants et de commencer un dialogue
ou en tout cas d'intéresser des veillées
dès le cm2 parce que je peux vous dire
il ya d'autres collègues parlementaires
qu'ils le font ils sont très très
demandeur est très content d'avoir cet
échange donc en tout cas je crois que
c'est opérationnel devrait se développer
alors s'ils peuvent en plus être lauréat
du parlement des enfants et visiter
l'assemblée nationale alors là c'est
génial mais c'est vrai que c'est des
lacunes plastique y gagne chaque année
mais c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
vraiment des dispositifs importants et
l'éducation la citoyenneté elle passe
forcément par l'éducation l'éducation
civique en fait et quand on puisse avoir
cette sensibilisation là et je vous
assure vraiment dès le cm2 ils sont très
heureux c'était lé témoignage que la
porte et merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
elodie écoute marque je pense qu'il ya
une question qui était tout désigné en
tant que ministre à la participation
citoyenne vient de paul qui est
également maire dans les yvelines et son
commentaire c'est finalement vote
électronique démocratie directe droit de
pétition référendum locaux donc un peu
tous les sujets qu'on a notamment abordé
ici est ce qu associer plus souvent les
citoyens aux décisions
ce ne serait pas participéà le
développement d'une culture démocratique
chez les citoyens qui sera aussi une
réponse à ce désintérêt pour le vote
est-ce que tu
connecté au micro peut-être
trouvez marque plus tard je sais pas si
tu nous entends marque
du coup si peut-être quelqu'un d'autre
souhaitait réagir peut-être michel tu
avais avec son expérience également à je
vois marque s'exprime puisqu'on l'enfant
est ce que vous entendez là et bien
c'est un salaire de marché en france
voilà merci ça marchera peut-être c'est
parfait je vous entends là et ben vas-y
est ce que tu veux que j'entends des
voix
mais paul oui oui on s'entend très bien
pardon de ce décalage avec l'écho que
tout le monde acquiesce un peu tout
simplement pour vous dire je partage
assez le sentiment qui est exprimé par
paul martinez que je salue au passage de
mobiliser l'ensemble des outils de la
démocratie participative la démocratie
la participation citoyenne alors quand
derrière participation citoyenne pour
commencer à explorer encore plus creux
que je n'avais fait avant le sujet il ya
beaucoup de formes d'engagement je vais
rejoindre ce que dit michel
au fond la volonté d s'exprime de
différentes manières de la part des
citoyens ce qui me permet de faire une
petite digression sur la sphère du voc
moi je le problème c'est pas de savoir
si les gens votent à 16 18 ans sait déjà
que ceux de 18 ans homme de 18 ans
votent au fond parce que c'est cesser je
trouve assez réducteur le débat de dire
si plus de jeunes avaient droit de voter
c'est à dire si on avait 16 ans à
participerait l'engagement la vérité
c'est que la plupart des jeunes ils ont
pas envie il ne considère pas que le
processus électoral que le processus de
vote est une forme de participation à la
vie de la société
il décide de s'engager de façon
différente
je fais cette digression parce qu'on va
voir le débat donc 10 15 jours jeudi
jour sur le regard de sarah et des
autres des parlementaires qui nous
entendons qui sont là laurence et lui
dis pas ce que je vois bien qu'on va
essayer de dire si vous voulez que les
jeunes s'engagent fou qui vote plutôt au
fond ces passages moi je pensais passer
la solution je pense en plus on a dit un
mot les uns et les autres tout à l'heure
la crise des gilet jaune et les crises
qu'on a devant nous montre qu'il ya
quand même en plus process
d'acculturation si je peux dire qu'il
faut développer pour mieux connaître nos
institutions parce que il comme dramane
que nous n'ayons pas réussi quand même à
élever un peu plus le prise de
conscience sur le niveau de connaissance
du fonctionnement de nos institutions
parce que je pense qu'une grande partie
de la difficulté tient et tiens ça est
ce qu'il faut aux risques à des outils
de la démocratie tvo mobiliser je pense
que c'est l'ensemble de ces outils qu'il
faut démobilisés mobiliser pardon sans
en faire chaque fois l'alpha et l'oméga
mais tout tout comment dirais-je tout
outil ou toute démarche où tout process
ou toute méthode qui permet de mieux
faire comprendre de mieux faire
connaître
que certains puissent y engager quand
d'autres ne ferons pas tout de suite
mais peut-être s'y engager ensuite c'est
des petits ruisseaux font les grandes
rivières si je peux dire ils ont qu'il
faut mobiliser l'ensemble des outils en
étant en tout cas sur les process de
participation citoyenne ou
d'associations doyen jean vocable avait
plusieurs angles parce que c'est très
large pour à chaque fois à la fois
prendre faire prendre conscience de ce
qu'est la démocratie locale
commençons par la démocratie le cas ça
aidera aussi au niveau national et puis
après permettent aux citoyens de sassou
s'ils atteignent ces décisions mais
voyez bien qu'on n'est pas sur les mêmes
sujets et process quand il s'agit de
d'une décision d'aménagement dans une
commune que d'une décision un peu plus
l'eau dans une commune et je pense que
c'est pas tout à fait les mêmes process
qui sont à l'oeuvre
quand vous décidez de faire mal
démocratie participative sur
l'élaboration d'un plan local
d'urbanisme
il me semble que ça nécessite des outils
une prise de conscience une
appropriation qui nécessite du temps de
la formation qui n'est pas la même chose
que le choix que frais des citoyens sur
tel ou tel aménagement
j'entendais je crois que c'est la ville
de paris qui disait on va faire la
participation citoyenne sur le pl oui on
va faire deux réunions de deux heures
oui disons que c'est pas en deux fois
deux heures ou deux fois trois heures
qu'on règle la question du père lui ou
du pmu de la ville de paris parce que
les nappes les enjeux sont démentiels et
que ça relèverait plutôt d'un processus
de convention citoyenne tel que nous
l'avons mis en oeuvre l'important c'est
pas galvauder les outils et pas de
vendre de la participation citoyenne
plus plus quand elle ne l'est pas parce
que ça viendrait ajouter du
désenchantement au désenchantement si
vous permettez 7,7 cette chose donc
l'important quand on l'a on se lance
dans un processus de démocratie
participative c'est de savoir où on va
on veut atterrir c'est à dire parce que
va être l'expression citoyenne à la fin
parce que par nature on doit pas la
connaître et pas la vouloir
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir un avis au
moins savoir ce qu'on en attend c'est un
oui c'est un nom c'est une amélioration
c'est un regard c'est quelque chose qui
vient éclairer la décision publique
moi j'ai toujours été dubitatif sur ces
sujets là sur les référendaires oui ou
non on dit vous êtes pour ou contre cet
aménagement
je pense que ça n'est pas de la
construction c'est l'été les gens face à
un choix binaire y compris dans les
choix locaux qui sont un peu qu'ils sont
un peu compliquées voilà ce que je
voulais dire merci beaucoup
alors on a des militants extrêmement
démocrate évidemment passionné par la
démocratie on en vient même à se
demander dans les commentaires s'il
faudrait pas un rendre le vote
obligatoire que c'est quelque chose qui
est envisagé aujourd'hui nous demandent
notamment nathalie pierre également
suggéré cette cette disposition c'est
que c'est le cas dans plusieurs pays du
monde y compris en europe avec nos
voisins belges par exemple est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui serait pour vous
nécessaire de réfléchir à cette question
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si laurence
il souhaite par exemple réagir sur cette
proposition
alors pourquoi pas c'est un sujet qui a
été à de nombreuses reprises proposé
d'ailleurs déjà dans des textes et qui
n'a jamais abouti parce que là encore ça
nous paraît être une possibilité de
réponse intéressant intéressante mais la
liberté c'est aussi celle de ne pas
voter donc le vote obligatoire et déjà
une atteinte à une liberté individuelle
mais nous connaissons nous devons
trouver des équilibres
nous connaissons déjà des atteintes
comme je le disais tout à l'heure et
conséquente à nos libertés individuelles
cela mérite sans doute un débat
actualisé au regard
des résultats des derniers scrutins que
nous avons connus mais jusqu'à
maintenant notre culture en france
or chez plutôt vers la liberté totale et
donc celle aussi de ne pas voter
très bien je sais pas si quelqu'un vous
souhaitez ajouter quelque chose sur ce
sujet du vote obligatoire je vous
regarde
mais je pense qu'on va passer un sujet
suivant c'est celui un petit peu des
territoires on nous dit aussi pourquoi
finalement allés voter alors que
certains territoires sont peut-être
oublié dans la ruralité dans les
quartiers politique de la ville ça
rejoint aussi la la plénière qu'on avait
précédemment
et finalement si les politiques n'ont
pas suffisamment de prise sur ces sujets
là pourquoi se déplacer pour aller pour
pour aller plus haut est ce qu'il y a
besoin selon vous d'agir là-dessus donné
peut-être plus de deux prérogatives de
compétences aux élus locaux notamment si
on parle de la démocratie locale à ce
sujet là également parlé du sujet qu'on
avait qui étaient je vais le retrouver
pardon oui du cumul des mandats là
dessus aussi c'était certain explique
que le cumul des mandats doit permettre
finalement d'avoir des élus qui agit sur
plusieurs tableaux à la fois et qui
permettent de prendre davantage de
décisions et d'avoir davantage de prise
sur leur territoire qu'est ce que pour
vous que tirez vous du bilan du de
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats
notamment aucune fonction exécutive
locale et une fonction parlementaire
peut-être michel si vous souhaitez
réagir par rapport à cela
à la fois sur ce cumul des mandats et et
cumul des mandats je crois qu'il faut
toujours se méfier et des grandes idées
et qu'elles ont peu à voir le cumul des
mandats locaux et une banda nationale
pouvait souffrir des critiques bien
entendu équipe
ouais il juste il est venu nourrir l
absentéisme nous mélanger les intérêts
locaux et les intérêts nationaux est un
point de vue et il y avait critiqué fait
mais empêcher parlementaire d'avoir un
ancrage local avec des responsabilités
locales
c'est une chose d'être élu conseiller
départemental et une autre est d'être
dans l'exécutif et prend des décisions
par exemple je pense que le
parlementaire a aussi besoin pour
exprimer et ses choix nationaux de
demain soir et du station d'avoir otéra
d'expérience en quelque sorte c'est
l'exercice d'un mandat local
là aussi c'est une question d'équilibré
moi j'ai été accumulé beaucoup j'étais
un des plus présents sénat c'est comme
ça donc autant on peut limiter le cumul
l'interdire comme on l'a fait c'est
peut-être beaucoup et on nourrir tous
les cas le risque d'avoir à quelque
sorte des parlementaires hors sol dont
il faut un risque dont il faut se méfier
alors là aussi recherchons l'équilibré
merci michel puisque quelqu'un d'autre
se tait réagir par rapport à ce sujet de
la démocratie sur sur les territoires on
a un exemple que je me permets de vous
citer qui nous vient de françois-xavier
sur la ville de bon temps à quelques
hoquets officie d'ailleurs d'avoir été
élu adjoint au maire récemment qui donne
l'exemple d'un travail de concertation
des habitants commerçants et
associations qui donnera lieu à un
référendum local pour valider le projet
à l'issue de ce travail de de quoi le co
élaboration par exemple je veux pas
revenir sur un sujet là aussi parce que
on a des commentaires de sucer le
conseil économique social et
environnemental
marc tu commençais sur ce sujet là entre
en saluant le travail thérouanne
balanant au parlement est ce qu'il est
possible d'en accroître la d'accroître
la participation citoyenne vis-à-vis de
cet instant cela on a l'exemple de la
convention citoyenne puisqu'il en est
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui a été
concluant et qui demain ce pourra être
réédité sur certains sujets et au delà
comment le faire vivre
comment faire vivre cette cette
dynamique des acteurs locaux des acteurs
pardon sociaux économiques et
environnementaux sur les territoires
également
je pense que marc tu peux
rôle si tu actives ton micro aussi
tomber quoi déjà active oui et calage de
leçons parce que justement pour le sang
et sur l'autre pour la visio donc ça
fait un peu de décalage et pardon pour
ceux qui nous regardent et pour qui ça
n'est pas très agréable
l'objet de la récente du cce oui c'est
je crois que j'ai comme je pense que mon
micro est activée désormais que vous
m'entendez et donc je pense que la
réforme du cse telle qu'elle a été votée
en première lecture à l'assemblée va
dans le bon sens elle porterait elle va
dans le bon sens parce qu'elle permet
elle permet au fond d'eux elle permet au
fonds de répondre à trois exigences la
première c'est celle de renforcer le
pouvoir consultatif du cce moi quand je
suis rentré en la matière quand j'étais
ministre des relations avec le parlement
je dois dire que je savais qu'il
discutait de ses yeux quand même j'en
avais lu des rapports mais j'en avais
une vision un peu comment dirais-je
distante avec le sentiment que cette
cette institution vénérable du palais
d'iéna était un peu à défaut d'être
démodé dès qu'elle est en fait quand
vous regardez les choses ce n'est pas
tant la faute du ses yeux que la faute
de ceux qui devraient s'en servir et
s'en saisir c'est à dire au fond les
parlementaires les deux assemblées
les ce qui allait d'ailleurs siège ou
c'est eux les organisations syndicales
puisque c'est un lieu assez miraculeux
je ne sais pas si on a peut-être pas de
ce champ là mais cette nationale est
assez intéressant de débats de dialogue
entre différentes parties prenantes qui
parfois se décharge pour ne pas dire
autre chose sur le champ république
mon premier sujet renforcer la partie de
consultation de faire de ce lieu là le
lieu plus qu il ya des tas l'organe
qu'on consulte sur l'état de projet doit
guider c'est de concentrer un certain
nombre de consultations à l'intérieur du
cse je trouve que ça renforce son point
de il y avait un sujet deux
modifications de son sa composition
reconnaissant que dans un certain nombre
de cas il y avait beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelait pudiquement les personnalités
qualifiées qui est qui
quel est disons que parfois ça pouvait
donner le sentiment qu'on vionnet
installé au cse des gens dont qui
finissait un peu comme des choix la
retraite leur carrière je pense que ça
lui à l'image du cee que le que le
président du cesa patrick bernasconi a
toujours été très soucieux de l'image de
cette organisation et le fait qu'on
puisse renforcer tout en diminuant le
nombre la place des gens qui sont
désignés par des organisations
syndicales par des organisations
professionnelles me semble intéressant
quand bien même il y avait des
personnalités qualifiées d'ailleurs
qu'ils étaient et renommé compétente
mais je pense que c'était bien de le
faire puis troisième sujet pour y
répondre donc plus précisément la
question
on a une expérience de la convention
citoyenne était en cours elle n'est pas
terminée ce qui est désormais le sujet
c'est l'atterrissage des propositions
des citoyens mené une expérience qui est
très riche et la volonté du président la
république et du gouvernement c'est de
faire en sorte quand même que comment
dire on puisse adossé au cee et faire du
cse le lieu où la participation
citoyenne vient s'organiser parce qu'il
a besoin de beaucoup de méthodologie et
donc l'idée c'est de conforter au fond
ce qui a été l'expérience la
participation citoyenne conforter la
place du c ie comme celui le lieu
l'organisation est après tout le sérieux
moi je trouvais plus légitime pour ça
l'organisation qui viendraient organisé
compilé permettre la participation
citoyenne l'idée du président l'habilité
du gouvernement étant de une fois que la
convention citoyenne sur le climat
aurait abouti nous puissions lancer
d'autres convention citoyenne mais il
faut déjà comme dirait ce que celle qui
a été lancée arrive à son terme dans de
bonnes conditions
ce qui n'est jamais sain et donc a
répondu c'est elle porte aussi là dessus
c'est de dire c'est là que peut
s'organiser peuvent s'organiser des
débats qui s'ils n'étaient pas
organisées dans des instances un peu
comme celle là on aurait pu y en avoir
d'autres mais celle-là je trouvais assez
pertinente ne pourrait pas s'organiser
au delà ou en dehors de la conflictuelle
était en fait faut trouver des lieux et
les organisations qui permettent
d'organiser les débats qui ne soit pas
conflictuel quand bien même le sujet
portait soit un sujet compliqué voilà ce
que je pense que je voulais rajouter ce
que je voulais dire
merci beaucoup marc on va clôturer nos
débats sauf si l'un d'entre vous tenez
absolument à énoncer une dernière idée
avant que avant concert qu'on termine ce
qu'on peut retenir donc c'est le souci
je rebondis sur les dernières choses que
tu que tu as dit marc le souci dans une
démocratie de maintenir le pluralisme et
de garantir le pluralisme des idées
toujours dans un esprit de construction
et non pas de conflit gratuit entre
guillemets le souci également d'élever
au travers de la démocratie la
conscience citoyenne on on citait la
marque fournier au début de notre
échange ça s'est retrouvé dans plusieurs
de vos interventions favoriser la
démocratie également à l'ensemble des
strates et sous toutes ses formes
on a vu une grande pluralité
d'engagement différents démocratique
avec toujours la démocratie
représentative et le vote au coeur du
système de décision publique
et tout cela étant accompagné d'une
valeurs cardinales de la démocratie la
liberté la liberté également d'exprimer
son opinion comme de la retenir
si si si tel est le choix du citoyen je
vous remercie pour nos échanges je
voulais faire un grand merci marc ça va
elodie michel et laurence pour pour
cette matinée et essayer des changes
merci de vous être prêté au jeu on a
répondu à beaucoup de questions d'
incident et retraite démocrates sur le
sujet on a répondu avec plus d'une
vingtaine de questions quand les poster
en commentaire donc j'invite nos
téléspectateurs à à garder ce lien pour
vous dire que ce qui suit entre midi et
13 heures ce sera le forum des députés
européens avec vincent chauvet qui est
le maire jeunes démocrates je me permets
d'autun également avec eux le dis on
voulait vous signaler un autre rendez
vous on vous donne rendez-vous entre
15h30 et 16h on aura en effet un nenê en
isère des jeunes démocrates cet été jean
noël le mentionner à vent tourner et des
nouvelles pratiques sur l'agriculture
des jeunes qui s'engagent dans
l'agriculture et qui ont des des
nouvelles pratiques sur l'élevage sur le
maraîchage donc on vous invite à nous
retrouver
entre 15h30 et 16h cet après midi un
grand merci à vous et donc vincent
collet je lui laisse la parole à partir
de midi merci